[Musique]
à
j'ai commencé la natation tout d'abord
parce que mes parents souhaitaient que
je sache bien nagé c'était vraiment la
base d'être à l'aise dans l'eau être
capable de se déplacer en toute sécurité
et bien sûr j'ai enchaîné sur la
natation avec des entraînements assez
régulier j'ai rencontré mes meilleurs
amis et puis voilà la suite en laponie
jusqu'au au plus haut niveau
international mais à la base c'était
vraiment pas apprendre à nager c'est une
cause pour laquelle je suis très
sensible
[Musique]
mon meilleur souvenir c'est peut-être
pas forcément associée à une médaille du
titre ou un record c'est sur mes
derniers championnats de france où le
façon spontanée des spectateurs se sont
levés et m'ont applaudi pour me
féliciter finalement de cette carrière
qui était plus derrière moi que devant
et ça mike ça m'a beaucoup touché ça m'a
fait chaud au coeur parce que c'était
quelque chose de spontané et c'est
vraiment la première chose qui m'a
cependant
de quoi sera fait mon avenir ça je sais
pas vraiment maintenant j'essaie de vrai
pour le plus grand nombre fait et j'ai
vraiment fait le choix de pam ont créé
un seul endroit pour accompagner un
groupe de sportifs les deux nageurs plus
spécifiquement vas-y la chance de
pouvoir aussi rayonner un peu partout en
france et porter ces messages de valeurs
d'intégration d'engagement qu'impose le
sport de haut niveau et puis on est à
l'aube des jeux olympiques de paris 2024
c'est très important de sensibiliser
l'opinion public de tout âge à la bonne
pratique d'un sport pour être en bonne
santé
s'épanouir